and well it seems like you said like you
know you had kind of control over that
then what made it go so haywire last
year the cameras really yeah is this
nucleus bad nucleus and did it do you
feel like you could go and back in it
would you have done anything different
to like from the top down like this is
how it is know what I don't know I think
it might have been inevitable man I
don't know if you could have changed
that I don't know if anybody could have
came in there and did anything different
I wasn't gonna change up anything
because my models always been successful
so why would it change all of a sudden
which the players I don't think I change
I think because the egos dangerous man I
noticed from own ego you know like my
career's changed a lot I've worked for
15 years and in the past year it's
really gotten a lot different yeah you
know and sometimes it's tough for me you
know I'm tough some dubbing we've gone
through stuff here with working with my
producer it's been tough for me to learn
to work with others but it's but it's
not for me to learn Who I am as I'm
becoming more of a but I have to be more
responsive and stuff you know it's we
all grow yeah and then it's been tough
for me I've had a lot of struggles with
it yeah and sometimes it's my own ego
sometimes it's insecurity you know it's
a little bit of everything you know I
think football coaches especially head
coaches are probably the most
egotistical humans on earth I think
football players are the most
egotistical people on earth and I think
that's where you get the head-butted
head butting going on but I don't think
I changed I think as the year went on
you can see my boss made a comment the
other day you can see in the show
because she watched it you could see on
the show how you just relax
give me the [ __ ] over this year because
you didn't want to be around those kids
those coaches nothing and and I didn't
and that's why I was without week five
to be honest with you I was thinking
about what I'm doing different next year
already Dana I already had the plan I
was doing it every night till midnight
or 2:00 in the morning 3:00 in the
morning in my office building this
year's team and is that because if if
you don't win that year if you don't get
to that hot like if you're not
undefeated then it doesn't really matter
or what is not just that I knew this I
knew that cutting the nucleus we had and
it was just a bad patch man bad batch
from top to bottom and I knew I was
starting over and I was gonna gut this
thing and we were gonna get back to the
basics and character first was what what
I was changing so I had to character
wrapped everywhere on the facility and
that was going to happen and that's so
that kid that German kid that I that I
hired that that whole issue happened
with I hired him to be a graphic design
guy and he was a manager came from in
overseas came out there and I got him a
job on campus and fed him every day
I said listen if you can help me wrap
this facility get it right nice I'll let
you be on the team you'll never play but
I'll let you be on team and what he was
gonna be on the team a soccer player I
don't know what he would have been but
you know he he he did a good job and I
let him in he helped me wrap that thing
getting all the day's going yeah I'm
gonna say a lot of said look good yeah
so you know that pace when I got there
man it was you don't even know we built
everything with these man and that's the
most rewarding thing I think the blood
sweat and tears you put in and when you
win it and that's the most rewarding
deal and anything but yeah he can't did
he backstab you a little bit I didn't
think it was that bad texting you call
my buddy Hitler I doesn't mean anything
to me it's like I don't give a [ __ ] it's
like it's a joke between friends and
it's a [ __ ] he called himself that
yeah and that's when he got there he did
that and and the team called him that
everybody called him that word yeah
digital Hitler I think is one of his
screen names yeah yeah it's crazy he had
he had the bank off book
he'd walk around with it he did it yeah
he did a lot of that it's all gonna come
out man the truth and entertaining is
man he did a lot of that stuff and the
kids were gonna kill a man after the
whole deal and even though I'm getting
investigated I'm having to protect that
kid from getting killed by the players
people don't know that and you know I'm
at it for it cuz you cuz they were
trying to fire me over it oh yeah wanted
you there yeah and they were like your
ass called yourself dead now you want
some 15 minutes of fame right and he you
see in the show I guess Greg I thought
depicted it right you know you see us
they're all kids are calling that well
I'm calling them at all you field in the
office he's laughing and giggling
because he knew and you see this text
messages that we're put in their their
their stuff scratched out yeah on the
media there's some stuff missing that's
unbelievable and how people take your
opinion and run with their own opinion
and run with it it's a text message
between two people who gives you it if
I'd say take Nick and I'm look I'm sorry
if I'm being a Hitler today or you know
let me ask you this did you know this
are my boss the president of the college
mmm-hmm was from Jewishness thing
hooha barnwood bar oh yeah I knew that
so he's up there saying these things in
the academic building I get wind of it I
bring him in the office i suspend them
he also I had a huge issue with him in
females females are coming to me left
and right like he's super scary to them
yeah and he's creepy Oh knocking over
he's hurt a little and I mean and I got
a [ __ ] you feel me so he's breaking he's
breaking into the weight room man and it
sounds like Selena this televator person
that killed a little ain't nigh [ __ ] man
I'm just telling you why don't you let
that guy go well I did i suspended the
guy and I cut I said you're done here he
immediately goes from there to the
[ __ ] academic grilling and doing like
the March and [ __ ] and the teachers hit
call me and that's when I send out to
Texas and I was really doing it as a
joke to say listen I'm trying to help
your save your ass but I'm your new boss
basically get your ass over here and see
me because you're not gonna do that [ __ ]
under my watch and in my program and
make us look bad as a football program
did so that's why I regret that I regret
doing that way because obviously
nowadays with the soft natured people
that we live in this culture society
they want to get 15 minutes of fame and
they're gonna blast you out and then I
don't blame the kids man I don't blame
the kid you don't blame him I don't
blame him I blame the cowardly grown
folks that pushed it
I get the kid a job on campus it's the
guy that employed him that pushed this
right and it's a giant it's ridiculous
because I'm not the president not the
president because the president seemed
kind of he doesn't comment on it in the
show but it yeah I mean I knew that he
was Jewish sure he seemed like it you
know and then and but then I was like oh
he didn't really comment on it then and
then he you know like I don't know if
anybody cuz we care
nobody here's the thing nobody really
cares about any of this [ __ ] nobody it's
like people write articles and then
people that are bored if I were in a
public figure I'm still there nobody has
a father the thing is the president
camera winning do you think that anybody
would this is the thing they had 130
years your one we went in there we beat
four teams that we they haven't beaten
30 years yeah we beat oh they got a
picture of other the independence
football team for like 25 years ago and
half of em on ice skates dude [ __ ]
shitty squad bro ah well that's what I
mean so we go five and four year what I
met a catcher's mitt on
I know I know sit vote five and four
year one yeah I mean unheard of so like
okay [ __ ] make sure we win it like then
we did I have one bad year and that's
that's not I wasn't worried about I was
like I'm never going to fight for a bad
year after what we've done here is
running years so that's why you're at
week five I was prepping for this year
right and I was already gutting it
getting ready for the program because I
think we would wanted all this year we
had a great staff I hired the best
recruiting class in my three years there
so it even been better going that
happens what could you have done
differently you think if you were
looking back on I mean what um man I
don't know man I don't know sometimes
sometimes things are supposed to go the
way they go man I don't know if you can
change something you know I didn't do
anything different it was you know the
cameras didn't bother me it was they
bothered other guys but I this is the
one thing I'll tell you which might
sound like jokingly as a joke I'll never
hire these young [ __ ] coaches again
so maybe I'll have a staff of [ __ ]
eight-year-olds next time I get a job
because those guys know the the intimate
setting of the locker room and when we
grew up in football football locker room
was the most intimate setting period now
it's a mockery it's a place where kids
want to film you cussing out the team
because Johnny stole at Walmart you
cussing out the guy and the team for
making an example of everybody so you
better not do it or this guy you're
gonna do end up like him cut or in jail
and they want to film you on the low and
right put it on social media and even
coaches young coaches I'm just like what
does this become everybody get their
clout and that's what's kind of gave me
a sour taste in coaching maybe I don't
want to do this no more if it's become
such a spectacle well there's so many
battles it seems like you have to face
not only trying to keep these I mean
you're also you're at the cert you're
like a second year you know you're at
the oh yeah you're a father but you're
also you're the tenth behind the big
circus it's like this is where to Anam
know don't know they got animals doing
cigarettes out here you know I'm saying
half the guy you know this where we this
is where all the shit's done and you
don't they don't show it like you know
there's a lot of things and you know you
could drug through the mud back there
they just show the good [ __ ] you know
dumping water on me when we win it all
like
you don't know what we had to go through
to win that thing you know I mean and
it's not like it's a 20 minute ride from
in Californians you call you taking 20
minute bus rides you know we're going to
Garden City's seven hours across the
state or to Iowa or whatever and you
know you got to deal with those kids and
hotels overnight no yeah
oh I'm sure especially with social media
now everybody's trying to [ __ ] each
other and all it is it's yeah it's a
it's a joke man it's becoming oh you can
[ __ ] somebody at a truck stop you know
saying if you got a fill if you filling
up a 30-gallon tank you'd have time you
know what I'm saying it's like these
days it's so easy to just cross paths
with someone go to am/pm or whatever
yeah um do you uh do you wish you were
still in Independence uh not how it
ended no because I just don't i feel the
course had ran its you know the times
ran its course
i think it was done it was time to move
on all good things come to an end I
built that placement I mean there's a
brand new turf field there
state-of-the-art locker rooms yeah
eating real nice you name it we I did it
and some sort of I missed that part of
it because I know what we were gonna
have it would have been the premier
place in America there's no doubt about
it
but at the same time man if I've never
kissed anyone ask man if you don't want
me there I'm [ __ ] leaving on my own
you don't got to beg me to leave and you
don't have to force me out I'm leaving
on my own and that's just how I was
raised man and so if you don't want me I
don't want to be here either and for the
most part I was wanted by everybody you
know 99% of that town wanted me there
man I get a lot of love emails from them
people to this day an independence man
and I love my time there you know to be
on a small town and all that but it was
fine with me I was there to do a job
which was to help young boys turn into
men and we did that too we excelled and
we did it better than anybody in country
and so we put our we put our footprints
in the sand man so to speak and we've
said history made history there and and
now maybe it's something it's a new new
venture to be had
what do you miss him right now about
coaching they interaction with the kids
you know I mean recruiting and getting
those kids uh finding the next Emma
Gooden or rocking Boyd or Malik Henry
and trying to save one of them because
you can't save them all so
my whole thing is save one of a man
because I tried to tell these young
coaches you try to save them all you're
gonna spread yourself too thin and be
super super heartbroken at the end of
the day I learned that as a young coach
and did you yeah and so you know now you
just try to pick one and save that one
kid and hopefully we save more than that
obviously but that's that's my goal and
so hopefully I missed that part of it
trying to find a guy to save again and
you know help these young cats out good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one